foreign
let's go to Darby in Buckeye Arizona
what's up Darby
hi John thanks for taking my call of
course what's up
um I just had some questions about how
to talk to my grandkids about their
mother
um choosing drugs and being homeless
instead of
um taking care of them
that's tough
it is tough
are you Grandma
I am yes
what happened in your daughter's life
that made drugs
the best solution that she feels like
will get her through her day
let's go because I thought that's about
this a lot
over
um biological father
just kind of
really didn't want a whole lot to do
with her
more so
um just kind of
you know she would go for a visit but
didn't really do much with her you all
divorced
yes yes long ago when she was
nine months old
um is when her dad left was your
pregnancy pretty traumatic pretty
stressful
oh very much
and that's the that's the biggest thing
that I can think of and then she had
gone through
um
some troubles with I I remarried when
she was five and we're still married
today
and we had a problem with my husband's
brother
and
he was inappropriately touching her
so we had to go through that whole thing
and she did some counseling
but she's just kind of always starvy
always looking Darby Darby
what
that's not kind of a problem with my
husband's brother
yeah it was a big deal
it was and we we definitely didn't
sweep it under the rug I mean we talked
about it and we did some counseling
but
um
that's like saying Darby that's like
saying a bomb went off and we didn't
just leave it we like cleaned up some of
the glass
that type of ah man
so where's her where's babies dad
um my granddaughter the oldest one her
dad is in North Dakota
okay well they're both in North Dakota
but my grandson's never met his dad
he's never been a part of his life why
not
um I've never met him
my daughter had moved to North Dakota
um when she turned 18.
and that's when she met my
granddaughter's father when she moved
all the way to North Dakota
my oldest daughter lived there yeah and
she just want to be on her own
sort of on her own well not at my house
so she moved there
and
um
so there was I don't know exactly
everything that was going on while she
was away
and so she had my granddaughter
and then
um it didn't work out with her
my granddaughter's father
and she met this guy I have never met
him
didn't know him very long they got
married she didn't even tell me
and then next thing I know
she left him she's pregnant
and
just not doing well so we
went back to North we drove over to
North Dakota and brought her back
we were living in Washington state at
the time
and she had the baby in Washington and
lived with us
but yeah we've never met
met his dad
so I think it's really important from
right now until the rest of your life is
is through
for you to never
say
my daughter is choosing drugs over
babies
it looks like that and for you and me
who are not struggling with addiction
that that algorithm makes sense on paper
but there is a hurt inside of her and a
disconnection and a pain that is so
profound
that the only thing
I I'm trying to think of something
minuscule like a time that my tooth
snapped in half
um and a root canal I had broke and I
had two exposed nerves
and I couldn't I couldn't see it hurts
it was pain that was in the ball of my
foot all the way through my body
and I went in my room and I shut the
door and I put my face down and I had
like a warm thing on my face in my mouth
was swelling up
and when my son I was like get out of my
room get out of here I got the pain was
so intense volume words anything
that's inside her soul
mm-hmm
so it's not a matter of her waking up
and being like you know what screw those
kids I'm getting high
this is not how that works
I've never in my life met an addict that
was like no dude I absolutely hate my
kids I love the state of my life right
now
I would much rather be homeless
than have a warm safe place to stay and
be with my kids
I've never met that person ever
so if I'm telling a nine and a
six-year-old this I'm little kids this
I'm telling a mommy is really really
sick
that's kind of what I've been telling
my granddaughter
for the past three years that she hasn't
seen her mom yes that's it mommy's
really sick right now and she loves you
very much but right now
she she doesn't love herself and she's
just really sick I wouldn't even say
that because listen part of your
your those little kids know that half of
them is Mom
and so any negativity to those kids
is negativity directly into their their
little Souls
mommy's really really sick
where is she now
she's in Phoenix
okay
yeah she
she went to rehab
um and March of 2020
but she um
she got caught with
with drugs on her possession so they
they kicked her out
very very common what kind of drugs is
she using
Choice I'm not exactly sure she just
says pills okay yeah
so it's been kind of a
a roller coaster a bit for definitely
for the last three years
and I just can I ask you a devastating
hard question
what was that I ask you like it's a
devastatingly hard question and I don't
mean this to be ugly I'm I'm asking this
for facts okay
instead of saying why is she choosing
drugs over her kids
why would she choose homelessness over
your house
what is it about your relationship and
her relationship with your husband
that is less safe than being on the
street
I would love to ask her that question I
would you be able to hear the answer
of course I would definitely hear the
answer
even if it hurt real bad
oh yeah yeah
it's very very common especially if
she's into opiates it's very common for
her to take multiple rehab stents
yeah I understand that opiates worse
I've been told opiates are
um if that if you know when someone
tells me they're all pulled out that's
usually what it means
they are chemically very similar to love
okay
and man that's somebody who's in
Desperate desperate need of connection
and it's really really hard to stay
connected to an addict someone who's
struggling with addiction I know that I
know that I know personally it's hard
and there's seasons of
like I I can't be I'm choosing to keep
myself safe I'm choosing my boundaries
and I'm choosing my relationships
um safety here I'm gonna create some
space
the route I've taken in my life is there
will never be a moment that you go to
sleep that you don't know that I love
you
and when you're ready I'm ready
yeah and I'll hear from
her every now and then mostly
um I'll hear from her boyfriend's mother
which we got in contact with each other
after we've discovered that we were
there
wait uh so let me just say this way that
plan isn't working
no but it's the only way I know
what what's going on with her would she
meet you for breakfast once a month no
she won't she won't meet me we've tried
that and she doesn't show up she says
she's going to
and she doesn't show up okay I saw her
one time
um I got a hold of her
because her number always changes so
what works today will not work the next
time of course
and I met her with some it was right
after Thanksgiving
and I met her with some you know I told
her hey I want I have some Thanksgiving
dinner for you and she was excited and
we met at a park
and
you know I tell her you know I love you
so much and I'm here for you
whenever you want to talk you can call
me we can meet and we can I'll take you
to dinner
you know you can't come to the house
because I and I don't know if I'm doing
the right thing but
I haven't allowed her
to see the kids since she left because
she's
she's not okay yeah and I don't want her
coming and going out of their life
especially my granddaughter my grandson
he really
doesn't remember her a whole lot yeah
but his body does his body does
he's he's kind of a different kid he's
got a lot of
right his body his body a lot of issues
yes yes here's the here's the deal
um
there's so many complex factors here
when we tell somebody who's really
struggling really really struggling
let's let's take
um
um let's say that your daughter's
throwing up she's barfing everywhere
and
she finally comes in in and you all meet
at the foot of her bed and you say hey
you're only allowed in here when you're
through barfing
so you stay in here don't come out and
when you're done barfing I'll be ready
for you
Emma close the door
it keeps barf off of everything it does
but it makes the work of relational
reconnection her problem the person
who's sick makes it their problem
and maybe it's not safe for you to crawl
into bed with her
but maybe
again everything you've tried so far is
not working
what if you just decided once a month or
once every two weeks I'm driving over to
the local IHOP and I'm just gonna sit
there I'm gonna text her and let her
know hey I'm here for our our breakfast
7 30.
and go ahead and take a book and some
work because she's probably not going to
show
and then show up the next week
and then show up the week after that
and maybe you're just gonna get a whole
bunch of work done and get some books
read that'd be cool
maybe one time she shows up
and you're not going to be there with
your advice and your lectures she's got
enough shame she knows she knows
there's not a thing you're gonna say and
she's gonna go ah I didn't know that
but Lego piece by Lego piece maybe her
body begins to feel safe
and maybe Darby none of this works
I don't know I got a daughter
and I just know I would storm the gates
of hell for that little girl
I also know loving somebody who's
struggling struggling with addiction is
a nightmare I know that
so I'm gonna keep showing up I'm gonna
keep myself safe keep myself in in my
boundaries I'm gonna keep showing up I'm
gonna keep showing up
not with my lectures not with my advice
but with pancakes
and an open heart
thank you
and maybe
maybe she'll come too
she's not choosing drugs over her kids
she's trying to stay alive the only
broken crooked way she knows how until
she learns another way
um it's gonna be a long cycle
if you can bridge that Gap
it's worth a shot